[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Andrew in Minnesota
what are your thoughts on balance
transfer credit cards I have three
credit card debts I'm paying off in baby
step two and the interest rates are
really high would it be wise to transfer
it to a zero percent interest rate card
while I am paying them off
the life hack of the balance transfer to
the zero percent card
how many have built their wealth Dave no
I'm not a fan of these balance transfer
cards and one of many reasons is that it
doesn't solve the root problem you going
into debt another reason is the three to
five percent they charge you just to do
this which means if you transfer 10
grand you're paying an extra 500 bucks
for the pleasure of continuing to be in
debt
with the zero percent offer that will
soon run out while you're still in debt
and then we're back to square one
so
while I'm paying off debt can mean a lot
of things
while I'm paying off debt over 10 or 15
years which means you're not really
paying off debt or while I'm paying off
debt for one year because I'm gazelle
intense and sold everything but the kids
and they're worried you know I mean
that's that's two different things of
while I'm paying off debt so
um while I'm paying off debt over 10
years which means I'm not really doing
it then I'm moving with George don't
bother because you're just kidding
yourself that you actually did something
interest rates aren't your problem the
guy in your mirror is your problem you
need to quit spending like you're
freaking in Congress if you're instead
doing the other way and you're like
gazelle intense you're paying it off in
one year then what you're saving is 18
of your balance or 26 percent of your
balance minus whatever transfer fees
there are and so you would save some
money but let's just kind of talk this
through for a second let's say
let's say net of fees transfer that you
saved I'll make up a number let's say it
was a 20 and a five percent fee so net
of 15. you save 15 okay if you save 15
off for one year on twenty thousand
dollars while you're paying it off well
you're not really saving it on twenty
thousand because during that year you
will have reduced it within six months
down to ten thousand so your average is
not twenty thousand your average is
about ten thousand that you're saving
the interest on does that make sense
okay this done math nerd here okay so
15 of ten thousand dollar savings is
fifteen hundred dollars on a twenty
thousand dollar balance
so is it worth it to save fifteen
hundred dollars on a twenty thousand
dollar balance in one year yes
but to George's Point does it solve your
problem no you have a twenty thousand
dollar problem you don't hit it with a
fifteen hundred dollar tool
you hit it with a twenty thousand dollar
tool which is you you be working you
butt off that's the tool yeah okay and
you be living on beans and rice rice and
beans and don't talk to me about you
deserve to go out to eat you'll be a
broke person in credit card debt you
don't get to go out to eat broke people
don't do that crap that's the other
piece is you have to actually change
your habits you can't just go up I
switched to the zero percent we're good
now I can keep living my life how I was
living and the problem is what I'm
trying to point out is the problem is
when you make this massive intellectual
calorie burning move right to make this
transfer and I'm beating the muscle
genius ah I've got the billion dollar
credit card industry on its back
punching it in the nose no you don't
okay they are punching you in the nose
this is why we're having this discussion
so you're not gonna whip their butt you
they're the 800 pound gorilla you might
take a little chunk out a 1500 chunk out
but don't think that that solves the
problem it's okay to do it as long as
you know that 95 of the problem still
stands there and 95 of the solution
still stands there and that be you to
your point yeah so do the transfer if
you want but don't act like don't strut
around act like you did something and
don't get comfortable because now with
zero percent you're going well it's fine
it's not gonna don't act and don't act
like you can do this odd infinitum
because that's what they're praying for
that they can keep haggling you hassling
you and punching you in the face and
it's time for you to uh just say you
know what I don't like the rules of this
game I refuse to play anymore I'm taking
my toys and going home you know I'm
going I'm getting away from you people
you I'm gonna put up a boundary you're
talking this is a toxic relationship
absolutely so what reminds me Dave I
just uh we uploaded this YouTube video
on my channel and reacting to this woman
who said hey velocity banking hack I
paid off my mortgage years early by
maxing out my credit cards and writing a
check to myself and then switching to
the zero percent cards one after another
and all of you should do this hack to
pay off your mortgage early it's genius
and so I broke it down on why velocity
banking is a scam but it reminded me of
this conversation about these balance
transfers
so they renamed stupidity velocity you
have to give it a cool name to keep it
hip because then you know infinite
banking you've talked about that I
thought velocity means statement speed
that's the anointment stupidity yes but
stupidity banking No One's Gonna no they
wouldn't sign up for that no oh so we
had to give it a different name infinite
banking Velocity Bank oh it's it's
stupid fast do stupid fast quickly fast
do do stupid quickly uh you know how to
sell things Dave you know how that works
it's just exhausting so here's what
they'll jump through interest rates in
almost a thing to remember the reason
debt consolidation doesn't work in
general is that 88 of the people that
take out a debt consolidation loan end
up going deeper in debt because they
don't change the person in their mirror
the problem with this whole thing is
it's a pain in the butt because changing
you changing me me changing me is a pain
in the butt I don't like changing me I
like the old me I don't I don't want to
have to go through the pain of growth I
don't like it I don't like the
discomfort of transformation and yet
that's what makes a better version of me
and so changing me is the hook not
changing the um technique or the hack
so change the you know if you want to
shift your balances that's fine but you
still have 95 percent of the problem
you've only addressed five percent of
the problem so don't strut around the
yard throwing your shoulders back acting
like you be bad because you're not you
haven't done anything yet you just moved
it around the shell still has a p under
it it's just a matter of which one the
con game on the street and you're just
playing the game you got you're getting
suckered again so it's there somewhere
you can count on it until you get rid of
the toxic relationship completely by
paying the stinking thing completely off
it's a big deal it's a big deal so
that's the difference in
see I grew up in the financial world as
a as a in the academic side of things
getting all the licenses and selling all
this crap and we are always taught that
the problem is a math problem
and it's just not
when it comes to your personal finance
it's 80 Behavior twenty percent had
knowledge it's in the psych Department
yeah wrong Department it's not a math
issue it's a behavior if it's a behavior
problem then the solution is a behavior
modification
solution yeah people think well the
problem Dave is the 24 interest if I
could solve that no the problem is the
guy who got your who got themselves into
24 interest debt
and if we can solve for that we've
solved for a whole lot more than just
this one little dinky debt oh and let me
tell you when you fall for stuff like
velocity
stupidity banking
um when you're desperate
or when you're greedy if you want to con
someone you need to find people if you
read I read a great book by a con man
one time he said if you want to con
someone find people that are afraid or
that are greedy
and if you so if you think that you're
the exception to the rule and you've got
the hack and you no one knows about it
but you
after all this time God selected you to
give him this what you've got to be
kidding me that's so greedy and stupid
and nice prod comes right before the
fall you just describe most of the
cryptocurrency community and now the nft
community they're really quiet now yeah
not making much noise pipe down where
are all you people that said George and
I were frauds well they made their
Millions now they're on the beaches Dave
they're not tweeting anymore
that sounds like velocity banking to me
now they're probably back at work
working their normal job that's a
velocity uh Philosoraptor banking oh
there you go that's a whole new banking
I'm signing up for that one Chomp Chomp
I know what happened to the dinosaurs
I'm not I'm not touching that one with a
10 football